oh yeah excuse me you just look like
someone who'd own a lot of cats
[Applause]
[Music]
you look fantastic
thank you yes you look so beautiful that
is an incredible dress sure that you've
been dipped into very well together yes
let's get closer shall we let's talk
about the myth of penis and size now I
have it on good authority that women
don't care for a large penis it can be
bothersome hopefully it will be um
hopefully will be a full moon and get
naked and just be out there for as long
as possible I did luckily there was no
one there so no one you thought no one
was there I'm a world-class pervert with
Google Maps
[Applause]
[Music]
such an idiot I'm sorry there yeah
[Applause]
the way that I met Simon was they asked
me to be a guest judge focus
Conan to be firm foaming cleanser why is
it called volume firm what's the burn
your skin does it firm up everything
[Applause]
what I would suggest is really take it
on
I feel outside and I peek in through the
window looking like this
[Applause]
gentlemen what do you think of my marry
table you're portraying Mary Lincoln
when she was on Maxim magazine oh yeah
totally I'm Maxim Katie use a little
underdressed
okay hands off there I think you look
absolutely stunning
here take it dinner anytime I have a
husband but I don't have a boyfriend
yeah oh good oh look at this guy here
this guy's got his creepy peeper glasses
on hey those are fogging up so is that
what Abe would do when he would see this
Mary dress like this well you're going
to get up and over I am very excited
about
[Applause]
I'm right I wouldn't
who's in there for God's sake
what did some boob implants in there
he's moving them something I don't even
know how you get the muscle to I mean
that's okay all right okay all right
pretty ready kid shop please you just
got hotter those abs
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
now this is fascinating you shot the
entire movie in Africa
[Laughter]
we look there throw it
[Applause]
but but it's about popping the booty and
you think popping the booty can help a
relationship is that the idea it can
bring fresh freshness to every now and
then you guys I start going somewhere
like looking over here I was looking
back this way over this area I mean I
like my bum you like your bum that's
fine
I have enough in the rump departments
happening on
you got that well because I don't have
that okay I've got kids completely flat
I have this what's that called
flapjack pop but now you dance with that
so you do sexy base and then you dance
right right and I'll feet I block this
out and you
this is fun this isn't okay
[Laughter]
just gonna go one cheek other cheek I
can't I have no ass what to speak up I
have nothing here there's nothing here I
have no nerve endings down here I have
nothing
what about one big just both cheeks
nothing's happening for effort that's
horrible nah you know I was looking at
some of your videos today these are some
of the sexiest videos I've seen they're
they're very you're very comfortable
with yourself and that's a good thing
I'm watching one video and you know some
of the shots it looks like you're not
even wearing clothes anyway it's in this
box let's make this an incredible year
this was expensive cost a lot of money
you have a lot of people that are big
fans on groupies but some of them what's
the age range here usually you know
teenagers just like some of the creepy
ones like the older guys like they're
like 40s and 50s 40s is old huh I don't
care I'm 32 I don't mind
31 I'm gonna be 32 in four year how are
you an exhibitionist you said you just
like you like to get attention anyway
you said something once that's gonna
stay with me I used to lift up my skirt
and I feel like that as a three year old
though I mean it's hot it's like a child
thing to do and it's she was three shut
up
what do you mean I look ridiculous
what if you were to club and you saw me
dancing alone here we go good thing I
wear shorts today oh